guck dir die kaputte Generation vor uns
an
wenn die mir sagen wollen ich mache was
falsch
die eigene Nase fassen also
muss einfach viel schaffen das ist
einfach so ist das so je mehr du
schaffst desto besser bis also gesund
oder
ich frage mich die ganze Zeit wie viel
schaffen die gut für mich und führe
Sally ich muss mich doch nicht dumm und
einfach schaffen sondern
man schafft ja zum Leben
Halt und was ist Diskussion ich glaube
nicht
wir brennt nur für den Job ohne selber
bewusst
ja du sie Gedanken
ich schaffe sehr sehr gerne und
dementsprechend auch viel würde man
sagen und was sie wirklich nicht haben
Balance glaube zumindest und deshalb
möchte ich ihre Reportage einmal darüber
reden was ist
was könnte die vielleicht anders machen
und wir machen das andere
also ich bin jetzt Akku da in Flawil im
Kanton St Gallen mit Besuchern das muss
hallo hallo
die nächste Station der online-pflanze
Shop face
bario deshalb weiß ich es wird zwar
geschafft doch aber gute Work Life
Balance wird da groß geschrieben
[Musik]
ich bin tatsächlich so ziemlich fertig
also ich meine ich bin ja kein
bonsmeister aber ich finde es schon ist
schon schön
bei mir ist es halt so dieses ständige
denken an Arbeit und also das kann
irgendwo nicht mehr gesund sein dann und
dann muss man einfach ein Stück zurück
drehen sie macht Social Media für das
Unternehmen der Stress sieht im Job
Community schlaft mir theoretisch könnte
sie Kommentare und Fragen über Pflanzen
rund um Turbo beantworten
einerseits ist natürlich auch so wenn
man antwortet dann antworten viele Leute
auch zurück oder schreiben noch mal das
musste das Video noch mal oder man lässt
es einfach
weil manchmal muss man man muss nicht
auf alles antworten was hier noch
interessant finde an andere Arbeit ich
weil es wird durch
Grenze will meine es gibt kein Grenze
die ist ja mega Fluid die man
weggegangen
Wochenende
beantwortet oder ist das wie im Prinzip
Begriffe wenn ich jetzt aktiv im Bus
oder irgendwie zu Hause noch was mache
dann mache ich die Ohren also wirklich
ja klar konsequent da kenne ich nichts
ich könnte mich auch entscheiden am
Wochenende nicht zu machen also ich
meine das ist ja doch
ich sag mal so
nicht zwingend dass ich am Wochenende
das wirklich wirklich mache also das ist
sowas es ist eher eine so Entgegenkommen
meinerseits
irisch Schäfer übrigens verantwortlich
zum Aufteilen
und ich kann ja praktisch neunte five
machen wenn ich möchte so also die
Option habe ich schon irgendwo das ist
einfach nur Willensstärke die ich nicht
habe
also
in die Richtung geht es ja dann schon
aber ich meine dass das Ziel ist der
nein du five Job das Ziel ist es zu
sagen
irgendwann haben wir das hier so
optimiert dass jeder der auch hier
irgendwie eine Position an der Stelle
hat nein to five Job hat
[Musik]
finde ich ehrlich gesagt steht jedem zu
so der Anspruch dass man nicht ständig
mit Arbeit sag mal belastet wird
nein also ich leiste anders als die
Generation vor mir
und ich würde sagen ich mache
im Vergleich das wahrscheinlich auch
besser als dies könnten und guck dir die
kaputte Generation vor uns an
also ich meine wenn die mir sagen wollen
ich mache was falsch sich mal an die
eigene Nase fassen also das ist so der
andere Ansatz ne also wenn ich mir
teilweise nicht die Leute sehe die älter
sind als ich und sagen oh die sind faul
und
[Musik]
so will ich halt nicht enden und dann
weiß ich wieder ich mache alles richtig
ich glaube das ist der Ansatz den man da
einfach sehen muss es ist einfach nur
mit der Zeit gehen
oh mein Gott ich merke gerade bin nie
ein Blume vielleicht wenn es uns schaffe
Gott irgendwie Show
in meinem Kopf wussten
für mich world einfach live und frage
ich nur ist es auch okay
ich bin jetzt in Zermatt gelandet der
Grund ist das Benjamin trifft er ist
leider vom Hotel leitet bei 120
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter und
erinnere mich am Telefon verzählt so vor
allem im Winter sind die Arbeitszeit
gerne mal 12 oder 14 Stunden und was mir
beide definitiv gemeinsam Handy sind
beide sehr Fans im eigenen Job also mir
leben Schaffer und das finde ich aber
ganz interessante dran wenn du den Job
liebst ist damit viel schwieriger zum
Punkt machen also ihr das auch schon
gar nicht an vielen ständige parallel
geschafft haben und noch insta und
Podcast und was weiß ich was die Macht
hat alles gern und dann
mache das einfach ohne zu realisieren
dass es eigentlich viel zu viel Arbeit
ist immer so lernen nice
schwierig für mich und all das ist genau
der Grund wieso die Repo möchte die
machen und mit Lied wieder reden muss
ich auch über work-life Gedanken machend
in dem Luxushotel ob Zermatt
Wintersaison ist gerade der letzte Zug
das Merkmale die meisten sind froh ins
bald Ferien endlich
das gilte dafür Benjamin wo der
Hotelmanager ist und wie viele andere
auch dir selber
machen
gut unterwegs genau
ziemlich wichtig
ich meine du musst so viel scharf er
schnitt Angst dass du den plötzlich
einmal also weißt du musst einfach dass
du
mir Sorgen kann ich am meisten wenn ich
nicht auf der Arbeit bin wenn ich frei
habe wenn ich in der Ferien bin wenn ich
irgendwo bin ich nicht kontrolliere was
läuft
da kann ich kontrollieren was läuft das
mache und wenn irgendwas Problem
aber das ist doch irgendwie krank also
wenn ich auch wieder Ferien
ja
[Musik]
schaffst
das
ganze Leben
shilfe
eigentlich
[Musik]
Kollege Familie Bezirk vielleicht gibt
es überhaupt nicht schaffen
das Ganze also natürlich eine Familie in
Basel
und das Video nicht besonders
viel Macht der Benjamin
er blieb ihm nicht viel Freizeit zum
irgendetwas anders
kein Problem
12 14 Stunden
schwierig da nur kurzes Mail Donald bist
du bereit und schnell notiere damit es
nicht vergiss einfach aus dem Büro um
mich komplett abgrenzen das kann ja
einfach nicht aber vielleicht kann ich
da oder falsche Job oder die falsche
Stelle ich
sie könnte sagen
in der abfahrtstation vom pflanzen-shop
gibt's
tief und wenig kreativ aber ein großer
Vorteil hat sich abgrenzen klappt gut
in ihrem vorherigen Job im naure-lader
ist das komplette gegen Taxi
das heißt lange Arbeitszeiten
Kollegen gesehen und das ist natürlich
schon mega Ratter Schwanz
ist oder so eine Angst davor hast und
ich wollte das einfach unter anderem
Umständen
Motivation da ist wenn du jetzt
quasi deine Angst
sind keine Motivation zum privat
genauso wird und genauso demotiviert
bitte geschaffen
stellt dir noch am nächsten Tag wieder
frisch und mit
mitgenommen natürlich auch viel
produktiver Tag
stimmt
vorher bin ich im Verkauf
Elektronik verkauft und das sind halt
immer sehr sehr lange Tags 12 Stunden
öffnungszeiten
ja der andere Jobsuche 200 % ich darf
sie nie Erfüllung und da ist schon mega
okay wenn man
was können eigentlich genau
[Musik]
überhaupt
und wie sie sagen das ist mega okay
[Musik]
einen schönen Tag Klaus wir gehen jetzt
mit der Lisa du beschließen
freut mich
egal wenn das schaffen will es ist immer
cool ja und klar
heit wenn ihre Freundin das motiviert
vom darf ich sie immerhin schnell am
Arbeitsplatz also früher Morgen sie sind
immer überpünktlich verzählt sie
nicht so viel los ist und mich wirklich
daheimer jetzt da mit meinem Freund
diskutiere ich das auch ab und zu wie
lange man das eigentlich
haben wir das mit 40 gerne machen das
Fragen und was ist Resultat von
Diskussion
[Musik]
würde mich freuen und ja bis zum
nächsten Mal